I sadly am going to discuss an interview
from CNN's new Caitlin Collins show that
is indicative of how far the United
States of America Has Fallen
specifically with regard to that other
party the Republican party and what they
now defend and support there is a
senator named Tommy tuberville
tuberville I keep hearing his name
pronounced multiple ways I don't know
okay tuber let's go with tuberville for
today and then tomorrow we'll say
tuberville he was on CNN's The Source
this is Caitlin Collins's new show and
it debuted last night and he was asked
about an interview that he gave NPR back
in May and during that interview when he
was sort of confronted with with his
seemingly uh lack of opposition to White
nationalists he said listen white
nationalists are Americans at the end of
the day and Caitlin Collins did
something interesting which is she gave
him the opportunity to explain clarify
and expand on those comments and
tuberville actually made it worse I am
the the lens through which I'm
suggesting you watch this interview
is that this is now the Republican party
where we are is playing footsie with
white nationalists and he actually at
one point says I don't know that white
nationalists are racist if they're
racist I'm against that stuff but I I
that's an opinion that white nationalism
is racist let's start with the first
clip this is uh this is sad as much as
it is outraging I do I do you a chance
to clarify
on
Terry for the
do you believe they should allow white
nationalists in the military well they
call them that I call them Americans
do you want to explain those comments
Senator yeah first of all uh I'm totally
against any type of racism okay I was a
footballer good to mention that coach
for 40 years and I dealt uh and and had
opportunity to be around more minorities
than anybody up here on this did you
guys catch that little slip okay so
there's two layers to what he just said
and I sort of stepped on it so we're
gonna go back and listen again
in
in order to prove how not racist he is
he goes I was a football coach okay so
he's saying
I dealt I I dealt with he actually used
the word I dealt with black people and
then he catches himself dealt with
sounds like it's a little bit negative I
had to deal with the burden of black
people
um and then he goes you know I and so we
had every minority it's actually
stunning that this quickly it implodes
okay I was a football coach for 40 years
and I dealt uh and and had opportunity I
dealt with no that sounds bad I had the
opportunity to have minorities okay
let's continue to be around more
minorities than anybody up here on this
hill yeah uh but when our military has
been attacked was being attacked after 9
11 after January the 6th and that was my
first day on the senate floor I thought
it was I thought it was outrageous of
what senators from the Democratic side
Chuck Schumer set on them so this is of
course not an answer floor that night
calling out people calling people racist
calling people nationalists white
nationalists white nationalists is just
another word that they want to use other
than racism uh I'm totally against
anything to do with racism but the thing
about being a white nationalist is just
a cover word for the Democrats now where
they can use it to try to make people
mad across the country identity politics
right totally against that but I'm for
the American people I'm from can you
imagine not wanting white nationalists
in the military is now identity politics
that is really something else and then
when Caitlin Collins really gets to the
critical part of this which is white
nationalists are racist that's that's
what makes the if you're a white
nationalist and you get rid of the white
nationalist beliefs you're just white
you're no longer racist the racism is in
that white nationalism he goes well
that's your opinion Caitlin you said a
white nationalist is an American it is
identity politics you said a white
nationalist is an American but a white
nationalist is someone who who believes
horrific things you don't do you really
think that's someone who should be
serving in the military well that's just
a name that it's been given I mean it's
not it's a real it's a real definition
there's Real Construction so if you're
going to do away with most white people
in this country out of the military we
got huge problems
is he saying that most white people in
the military are white nationalists and
therefore if you got rid of the white
nationalist in the military
you'd have no white people left at all
is that what this guy's saying he's
digging the hole deeper and this is the
Republican Party Laura White it's white
nationalists that have a few probably
different beliefs right they have that
have different beliefs now if racism is
one of those beliefs I'm totally against
it I am totally Against Racism
is racist Senator well that's your
opinion that's your opinion but if it's
racism if it's racism I'm totally
against it so listen
um
the three main ideas of white
nationalism are number one white people
and by the way it's always real white
people right like it's it's European
white European Americans white people
white people are threatened by race
mixing
multiculturalism
immigration of black and brown people
the low birth rates of whites Etc that's
one belief that's a racist belief number
two
white people should be seeking some kind
of a white only state a white ethno
state to preserve racial Purity and
identity that's belief number two of
white nationalists and number three
typically white people are also Superior
to non-white people now sometimes they
they know that that one's not as
palatable as some of these others so
they'll stop short of that they go
listen I don't have to weigh in on
whether white people are superior or not
but we should certainly be separate for
sure those are the if you remove the
white nationalism then it's no longer
white nationalism and what Tommy tuber
Bill is saying of course doesn't make
any sense this is where we are in 2023.
Republicans
multiple times even when given the
opportunity to clarify restating
that white nationalists are simply
Americans maybe whose views differ but
they aren't necessarily racist and uh of
course part of this is this environment
in which Trump has sort of normalized
you never back up you never backpedal
you never apologize and in a sense I
understand the reason for that because
if that's the way Trump sets the tone if
these guys start apologizing and
backtracking then all of a sudden they
seem weak and they're called beta and
all of this different stuff but the
problem of course is that people
sometimes do say the wrong thing and now
the tuberville is just doubling down on
it it's really wild stuff and we'll see
what the next follow-up is on this if
there is any think of your most personal
emails if you're using a free email
provider you should know that they're
scanning every email you send and
receive even after you delete it they're
usually using the data to build a
picture of your life to show you ads
which many find creepy our sponsor start
mail never scans or tracks your emails
privacy is what comes first and unlike
other email Services when you delete an
email in start mail it is gone forever
it also protects your data by blocking
tracking pixels and emails which
companies and hackers can use to track
you you can create unlimited email
aliases to protect your identity and cut
down on spam you can encrypt every email
you send even if the recipient isn't
using encryption start mail gives you 20
gigs of storage that's more than you get
on Gmail and it only takes a few clicks
to migrate all of your emails and
contacts over to start mail go to
startmail.com Pacman to get 50 off your
first year that's only about two bucks a
month the link is down below